vamos con este siguiente problema nos
dicen sean p q r y s puntos en el plano
cuyos vectores posición son menos dos y
menos j
este es el menos dos menos uno el 4 y
que es el 4 0 3 y más 3 jota y menos 3 y
más 2 j
respectivamente el cuadrilátero pq rs
debe ser 'un y nos pregunta bueno aquí
nos dan cuatro opciones pero vamos a
dibujarlo para saber de qué demonios
estamos hablando a ver vamos a pintar
los ejes más o menos derechito
a pintar el loto se llame fue muy muy
chueco
con más derecho
ok buenos quizás el final no fue tan
derecho vamos a quitar ok entonces ahí
tenemos nuestros ejes y ahí es en donde
vamos a pintar nuestros cuatro puntos
que nos van a definir el cuadrilátero
entonces digamos que aquí está el 1 el 2
el 3 el 4 y digamos unos 2 3 4
uno dos tres cuatro
uno dos tres cuatro más o menos los hice
derechitos para que veamos realmente qué
es lo que estamos pintando entonces
ahora vamos a dibujar estos cuatro
puntos digamos empecemos con p p es
menos dos y menos j es menos dos y menos
j aquí está nuestro punto p y este es el
vector posición
este es el menos dos menos uno muy bien
vamos ahora a pintar el q el q que es el
4 y que 4 y es este de aquí verdad solo
nos movemos 4 a la derecha éste es q
este es el 40 muy bien ahora vamos a
pintar r&r estrés y más 3 j
estos 3
3 más o menos por aquí
este es el 33 y finalmente vamos a
pintar el vamos a pintar este que es el
s menos 3 y + 2 j entonces nos movemos 3
a la izquierda y 2 hacia arriba
y lo pintamos muy bien entonces ahora el
cuadrilátero es el que se forma de unir
p con q digamos estos dos se unen
ahí está luego q con r
y luego reconoce
y luego s con p s me costó mucho eco ni
siquiera parece cuadrilátero más o menos
entonces a primera vista se ve que como
que no es definitivamente un cuadrado
mucho bueno tampoco sería un rombo
verdad este lado este par de lados son
mucho más chicos que estos dos de arriba
bueno el de arriba y abajo y realmente
estos ángulos como que nos sugieren que
tampoco va a ser un rectángulo verdad
entonces como que a primera vista
cuadrado no es y tampoco rombo porque
los lados no son iguales rectángulos se
ve como que no porque los ángulos no son
todos rectos entonces la respuesta en
este caso sólo de ver el dibujo es un
paralelogramo que no es rombo ni
rectángulo
recordemos que un cuadrado justamente
son este cuadrilátero donde todos sus
lados son iguales y todos sus ángulos
son de 90 grados el rectángulo no hay
que pedirle que todos sus lados sean
iguales
aquí vamos a dibujar lo mejor
que no hay que pedirle perdón que todos
sus lados son iguales solo que todos sus
ángulos sean rectos es decir de 90
grados y el rombo es un cuadrilátero
donde de hecho es un paralelogramo donde
todos sus lados son buenos sus sus lados
opuestos son paralelos muy bien pero
todos sus lados son iguales entonces en
este caso no es ninguno de ellos vamos a
calcular las pendientes de estas líneas
para ver que en efecto es un
paralelogramo si vemos que la pendiente
es decir si vemos que esta de aquí esta
línea de aquí es paralela a esta de aquí
y que esta de aquí es paralela a esta
otra entonces es un paralelogramo muy
bien entonces eso lo podemos hacer
calculando las pendientes de estas
líneas
primero calculemos la pendiente de esta
línea de aquí y simplemente recordemos
que es la elevación entre el avance y el
avance pues puede ser dos más otros
cuatro son seis
el incremento son 1 verdad estamos en
menos 1
en otras palabras tengo 0 es éste menos
menos uno dividido entre 4 - menos 2 y
esto simplemente es 1 sobre 4 2 que son
6 la pendiente de esta línea azul son 6
vamos a ver cómo cambia y cómo es la
pendiente de esta línea ok entonces la
pendiente de esta línea tenemos aquí me
faltó anotar qué punto era era el menos
3,2
y entonces la pendiente es 3 menos la
coordenada k que es 2 entre 3 menos
menos 33 menos menos 3 y esto
simplemente es 1 sobre 6 entonces si
coinciden las de las líneas azules vamos
a ver la de las líneas rojas y en
realidad solo estamos recordando que la
pendiente es la elevación elevación
entre el avance de verdad entre el
avance por lo que nos movemos hacia
arriba o abajo entre lo que nos movemos
hacia la derecha o izquierda entonces si
nos damos cuenta aquí la elevación en
realidad podemos pensarlo de esta forma
que en realidad estábamos en 3 y bajamos
a 0 entonces la elevación es de menos 3
y cuánto avanzamos hacia la derecha pues
fue de hecho avanzamos hacia la derecha
una unidad entonces esto es menos tres
ahora bien cuánto avanzamos
entre este punto y este otro
bueno pues avanzamos 1 verdad fuimos de
menos tres a menos dos y luego fuimos de
dos a menos uno entonces tuvimos que
bajar tres así que la pendiente aquí es
menos tres es entonces estamos diciendo
que que estos lados los lados digamos
este opuesto son paralelos en los azules
son paralelos y los rojos también así
que como son iguales las pendientes
estamos hablando de un paralelogramo y
de hecho podemos ver que no son
perpendiculares verdad dos líneas son
perpendiculares si la la pendiente
digamos de la línea es menos uno entre
la pendiente de la otra y aquí vemos que
uno es uno entre seis y menos uno entre
1 entre 6 bueno el inverso de 1 entre 66
y con menos sería menos 6 que no es
menos 3 así que no son perpendiculares y
no estamos hablando ni de uno ni de un
bueno de un rectángulo también se ve que
los lados no son iguales así que no
puede ser un rombo
y mucho menos va a poder ser un cuadrado
entonces espero que estas técnicas
geométricas te hayan ayudado a ver cómo
resolver este problema